Welcome back everyone this will be my new she-hulk
world war hulk and thunderbolts video about how
marvel is using she-hulk to set up these future
projects and storylines a lot of you spotted some
of the easter eggs and the teasers where they were
trying to set that up in the background during
episode one so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i will be doing videos for
all the episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just post all your theories about
thunderbolts and world war hulk on the video
there's a few easter eggs in this thing that
kind of let us down to believe the the world war
hulk storyline are you up for a solo hulk movie
anytime they want to do it i'm here kevin has
obviously revealed that all this is going to
kind of event and end in avengers secret war um
how do you think this will compare to end game
what do you what do you think what can you tell
us what can you tease us with well it's going
to be hard to top end game but if i know kevin
and i know marvel it's gonna be pretty amazing
it'll be a big bang we'll go out with a big bang
all the marvel disney plush shows are intended to
help set up some of the future movies and future
arcs for multiple characters just in general like
all of them are meant to feed into the future
movies really good examples wandavision was
meant to set up doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness moonite was meant to help set up
werewolf by night which we'll be seeing this
halloween even though we haven't had a trailer yet
the blade movie midnight suns the more mystical
darker characters in the mcu just in general
the she-hulk series is no different it's not just
about doing her origin story and her eventually
crossing over with avengers 5 and avengers 6.
there's a whole lot of other stuff they're setting
up in the background not just episode one like
some of it was very obvious some of it was less
obvious there'll be more scenes like that setting
up future movies and later episodes too including
the future of bruce banner's hulk storyline across
avengers 5 kang dynasty avengers 6 secret wars and
even before that the thunderbolts movie which we
actually just found out is meant to be the end
of marvel phase 5 officially rewind to the events
of the incredible hulk with edward norton during
episode 1 there were a couple references to the
events of this movie it's important because it's
like the last major movie where we saw thunderbolt
ross like really going up against the hulk himself
now he kind of referenced him during captain
america civil war but like the last big movie that
we had where they're going at each other legit is
during the incredible hulk movie during avengers
end game they're both in the movie but they were
both at the funeral they weren't really going at
each other a really good example of the references
to incredible hulk are bruce banner making this
huge deal about incinerating the she-hulk's
blood samples to prevent anyone from using them
to create more hulks that was also meant to be a
bit of a joke about the stan lee cameo seeing an
incredible hulk where he gets dosed with hulk's
blood because of the soda but also during that
movie the leader was using samples of his blood
to try and recreate his powers eventually using
the process to create the abomination as we see
him even though his look has evolved over time
like obviously he looks very different than he did
during incredible hulk what do you mean my blood
bruce this is all you you didn't send me much to
work with so i had to concentrate it and make more
there's no end to what we can do he even
accidentally turned himself into a more
comic book accurate version of the leader and
kevin feige said that he's still alive out there
somewhere until we see him again originally
in that movie thunderbolt ross had said that
when bruce banner had his initial gamma accident
became the hulk for the first time he had lied to
him when he signed on to the project thunderbolt
ross told him that he was going to create this
new beneficial thing like it was going to be for
the betterment of mankind but secretly thunderbolt
ross revealed to abomination that he was actually
having him work on the weapons plus program
the hulk was basically like the
next iteration of the weapons plus
weapons plus is like the larger name given to the
military's super soldier program so like captain
america was weapon one isaiah bradley for example
who became a version of captain america after him
would be like weapon 2. wolverine for example
people call him weapon x technically the x stands
for roman numeral 10 so he'd be like weapon 10.
technically because of what he was working on the
hulk is also part of that weapons plus program
there are even some deleted scenes during that
movie with red hulk easter eggs where thunderbolt
ross was trying to set up the character in future
sequels originally the incredible hulk
movie was going to be a trilogy of movies
for our nation and for our way of life i intend to
put a harness around it typically what marvel does
is when they have really cool twists or deleted
scenes like that with cool plots that wind up just
not making it into the final cuts is they'll
just bring them back in future films like oh
we'll just use a version of this twist in a future
movie or future storyline the grey hulk is another
good example in avengers age of ultron when they
were trying to create the hulk versus iron man
fight in avengers age of ultron they pushed the
special effects so hard like they made him look so
crazy that he started to look like gray hulk and
they're like you know what we'll dial that back
and you can use grey hulk in a future movie if you
ever want to during the recent episode of she-hulk
they filled in a lot of missing backstory and
details about what hulk had been doing the past
couple of years since avengers end game how he
was able to become smart hulk in this laboratory
balancing his two halves and how he was able
to heal his arm after using iron man's infinity
gauntlet the funny thing about that is that when
avengers end game actually came out in theaters
the russo said that his arm would never heal so
this should give you an idea for how sometimes
the directors of marvel movies the writers and
kevin feige the other producers won't all agree
on what's canon and what's not canon that's why
when you ask the directors a question they might
give you a different answer than someone like the
writers they also established that just because
jennifer walter's blood was contaminated with
hulk's game of blood and she became she-hulk just
because she's another hulk doesn't mean that the
gamma in her body causes the exact same effects
that was to set up the concept that her powers
the way her hulk forms work won't be exactly
like bruce banner's hulk forms and when i say
hulk forms that just means every single possible
version of the hulk that they could become in
what their powers would be they do share some
of the same powers like the power scale the
same way based on their rage so with each one
the matter they get the stronger they get but
that's just to explain how her full hulk form
like savage she-hulk will be different from his
full hulk form like world breaker hulk during the
scene where you see hook versus she-hulk fight is
super quick but for just a brief second he starts
to lose control he's still holding back like you
can tell that he still has some control he's not
trying to kill her or anything he's just trying to
teach her a lesson not smash her into a fine paste
but for just a brief second he starts to
lose it like he's on the edge of control
and earlier they had this conversation about
how hard it was for him to deal with his
trauma as a child balancing his two personas
whereas jennifer walters doesn't have some of
the same violent trauma from her childhood that
he had but they are trying to let you know through
a lot of these scenes that she will eventually
lose control and he will eventually lose control
that's what the whole scene about her not thinking
that she had an alternate persona was about like
i don't think that i have one like oh yeah you
definitely have one we just haven't met her yet
her name is the savage she-hulk and on the other
side of that the hulk losing control becoming a
version of world breaker hulk that's where you
get to world war hulk in the thunderbolts movie
the spaceship from sakhar had a secret message
just for him that's plot that they'll pay off
eventually to it might have something to do with
this world war hulk storyline world breaker hulk
him just losing control him becoming so angry that
eventually the rest of the world both the avengers
and the thunderbolts will have to take him down
but i think it's also meant to help seed his plot
into avengers 5 at avengers 6 secret wars as well
like further on marvel's supposed to get the full
rights to the hulk movies back next year there's
not a hulk movie on the marvel phase 5 schedule
because they can't even start talking about making
a new hulk movie until they get the rights back
so like in 2023 then they can actually sit down
and say you know what we should do a hulk movie
kevin feige clarified it was the same situation
when they knew that they were gonna get the
rights to the x-men back back in 2019 that was
around when avengers end game was coming out
but their fox deal didn't close till a little
bit after that they couldn't actually sit down
and start talking about doing a new version of the
x-men until after the deal had actually cleared so
even though they don't have time in the schedule
to actually do a solo hulk movie for a couple
more years they can do a world war hulk style
plot line across thunderbolts avengers 5 even
avengers 6 secret wars which has basically been
their way of doing hulk arcs without doing a legit
solo hulk movie for the past several years just
spread his storyline across a couple movies they
do have the rights to do whole tv shows though
that's how they're able to do the she-hulk series
getting to the thunderbolts of it all so she
hulk also meant to help set up the abomination
joining the thunderballs he's sort of like the
version of the hulk on the team because they're
kind of like a dark version of the avengers there
is a dark avengers team in the comics but because
they put thunderbolts literally on the board as
a marvel phase five movie i think they're just
going with the thunderbolts and if they use the
dark avengers it'll just be something that they
call the thunderbolts team in the movie and now
based on what's happened in the marvel movies and
in real life the last couple years i think it's
a foregone conclusion that val will take any of
the storyline the thunderbolt ross might have
had previously before william hurt passed away
so if they don't recast thunderbolt ross for
example red hulk would have to be a completely
different character there have been other red
hulks in the comics so it's not a really huge deal
but all the different val cameo scenes now where
she's recruiting people that we've seen have been
her recruiting the thunderbolts team also a
lot of you will remember that the thunderbolts
first appearance was inside an incredible hulk
comic book so here's the whole connection to
the thunderbolts team the early theory is that
one of the thunderbolts missions like one of
the big reasons that they all come together
will be to take down a version of the hulk
val implied that there's going to be missions that
they go on that they can't rely on the avengers or
the new version of falcon captain america on and
that would be to either take down or kill the hulk
like everybody's buddies with the hulk they're not
gonna kill their buddy it's sort of like a captain
america civil war bucky captain america situation
he's my friend like they cause civil war because
he would not take down his friend world war hulk
is basically like the version of that with the
hulk at the center of it and i think that whole
easter egg with she-hulk's blood healing hulk's
arm so quickly healing his body so quickly is
then trying to assess the concept that the new
avengers can use she-hulk to eventually save the
bruce banner hulk when he does lose control and go
full world breaker hulk but if you spotted any
other world breaker hulk or world war hulk or
thunderbolt's easter eggs during episode 1 just
write them below in the comments we'll see more
easter eggs for this stuff in the future episodes
there are nine episodes total so like this is
just the beginning but like i said the series is
meant to help set up a bunch of future movies and
a bunch of other storyline we just got a brand new
she-hulk trailer with a bunch of new daredevil in
it so i might do a video for that next also a big
reminder house of the dragon episode 1 is starting
tomorrow i will be doing videos for that just
like i did for the main series everyone click here
for my full she-hulk episode 1 video and click
here for my house of the dragon episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!